in Western Ukraine Russia has fired 13
cruise missiles at an Airfield that were
intercepted according to the Ukrainian
military air raid alerts were held
across the country overnight on Thursday
drones and missiles targeted areas from
leviv and the Far West to Castle in the
south
Russia says Ukrainian forces have killed
one person in the region of zaparitia
that happened in a village in the
Southeastern front line both sides of
intensified shelling Ukraine says
Russian forces killed three civilians
further south in Carson
Russian intelligence agents say they've
stopped a Ukrainian plot to obtain
radioactive material Russian State media
has released pictures of the raid the
FSB Security Service says five people
were detained while trying to buy a
kilogram of cesium for three and a half
million dollars it says the group was
working for a Ukrainian citizen
the U.N security Council is holding a
briefing on the ongoing war in Ukraine
the U.S ambassador to the UN has accused
Iran of not only providing Russia with
hundreds of one-way attack drones but
working to produce these weapons inside
Russia the U.S and its allies are
calling on the Secretary General to
investigate these violations our
diplomatic editor James Bays is joining
us live now from the UN in New York
James we just saw pictures there of
Vaseline abancia the permanent
representative of Russia talking to the
rest of the security Council clearly
responding to what's been said what has
been happening over the last couple of
hours
well this is a general briefing of the
security Council requested by Albania
which is uh very much an ally of the US
on the situation in Ukraine uh but what
we have heard in this meeting and
actually just before the meeting when a
group of ambassadors came to address
reporters is uh further allegations of
Iran's involvement with the Russians uh
in providing drones to the Russians to
use in Kiev the U.S ambassador Linda
Thomas Greenfield said that there are
hundreds of Iranian drones being used by
the Russians and that they've been used
again in recent days she also says the
U.S has Intelligence that there is a new
drone Factory that is operating inside
uh Ukraine uh that are run by the
Russians and the Iranians to produce
further drones and she says there's
intelligence from both the U.S and the
UK that's been provided to the United
Nations she says it's time for the
United Nations to take action
Russia's and Iran's actions violate U.N
security Council resolution 2231 that
resolution prohibits all countries
including permanent members of the
security Council from transferring these
types of weapons from Iran absent
Advanced Security Council approval
Ambassador the Secretary General says he
doesn't have a mandate to investigate
what do you say to that
2231 resolution 2231 does give the
Secretary General a mandate to carry out
these investigations and we have all
encouraged the UN to move forward on
carrying out these investigations
immediately
slight correction to what I just said I
mentioned that that Russia and Iran are
collaborating according to the US on a
drone Factory uh that's not actually in
Ukraine it's it's in Russia
um the Russian ambassador to the United
Nations was listening uh to the U.S
ambassador when she was giving those
comments he came then to the microphone
to report us and made it clear that he
was not in favor of any sort of
Investigation I put it to him surely if
you've got nothing to hide uh then why
and if you're not using Iranian drones
why don't you let the UN investigate his
answer was well he doesn't believe that
resolution 2231 gives the Secretary
General the power to launch an
investigation who doesn't think a team
that works on that investigation have
the capabilities to launch any such
investigation so you've got quite a
number of Western countries saying they
need an urgent investigation saying the
secretary generals should not hesitate
he has the power to launch one Russia
saying no no no the Secretary General of
the United Nations right now is in a
difficult position uh diplomatic editor
James bays at the James thank you very
much indeed as always